たまに頭おかしいと言われます肇社長です世間的には僕行く頭をがせって言われるん
ですよ多少の自覚があるんですけどもあのどのレベルなのか僕は分からないまあ今や高
ユーチューバーとしてを過ごさせていただいてますけども僕このまま100回100回
僕がこのも性に出ても大丈夫だったのかどうかとかたぶんあの自分でやるなんですけど
僕堺不適合さの
可能性です多々あると思うんですよ自分でもわかってるんで相当ヤバいやつなんです
ぼくそれが本当なのかどうかはたまた嘘で僕は本当は普通の人間ならばダークトライ
アドテストというものがございます
うわぁサイトがあるんですけども再度なんかすげー怖いのはこういう音無機質猫が一番
怖いこのテストは人格のジャークな気質を取り扱っていますこのテストを実施すること
うんより自分自身のジャークな気質特製つまりダークサイドが明かされ
人によっては動揺してしまう場合もあります
だから聞いた話によるとこれでねやっぱその人の悪い部分とかマジで見えるらしいんで
やるときには気を付けて下さいダークトライアド診断って検索したらすぐできるので
相手を始めていきますをダークトライアドとは社会的に望ましくないきしてる
ナルシシズムナルシスト的な奴に舌骨中的なマキャべリアにズームとサイコば c の
三つの人格特性のそうそうですダークトライアドテストこので
人は大企業でも使われてるしダークとレイヤードのスコアが高い人犯罪評価したり法的
な問題起こさせる構えが叩く
嫌いにならないで女が悪いが全然ですけどなんかこういう気が過ぎたらまた友人関係の
職場において問題を引き起こす傾向が高いという調査研究が示されていますまた一方で
ダークトライアド特定の人がリーダーシップ技術は融資
高い社会的地位を持つと見なされていた日朝長だ
やばいこれだ比較的容易に望ましい性的パートナーを手に入れやすいことを示すという
調査研究もあります
マジでいい特許庁もあるらしいんですね発朝がイカれてるひとっていかれていたって
やっぱその危険なことも犯す可能性もありますしそれだけ人と違うんでいろんな人がし
ないようなことを率先してできたりするんですよという良くも悪くもみたいなところも
あるんですけども早速やっていきたいと思います私はしばしば良心の呵責を書いている
自分を責めるようですね
質問の意味がわからないどういう意味だ自分の良い心のを責めることをし
じゃあも自分いいと思ったらいいですけどね私は家族と友好な関係を保ってもちろん
ですめっちゃ仲いいですよ全然中に社会的状況において優位に立っている
ゆいかは分からないんですけど一応正社長お経がやらせてもらってますいいほうじゃ
ないですか
in 的であるけど生で出資するよりももっと重要であるプレーヤー
それは人によってじゃないですか重要であると思いますけど私は他の必要に優れている
ベッドねー
いやーモノによってから相当アホなところもあるんで
場所によってやって指で多くの人たちは滞在になり必要に迫られない限り一生懸命に
働かないものだ
ん
そういう人は多い気もする行動の道徳性に気を遣うのは敗者がせることがすごい質問し
てくるな行動の道特選気を使う
いやそんなもうさぁ六ツ美
歯医者でも勝者のする人はするでしょ私は特別な名声あるいはちーについての空想
質問が変異率はトップいえばと者やせてもらってますから
空想というかも現実みたいなある誰かが住んだ時私は他の一言動揺しないと
[音楽]
そうかもしれんなってがみんないつか死ぬから別に死んだところで自然なことだと思う
とより動揺しないと思いますめっちゃ何か大事な人とかだったら動揺しますけど他も
一言ではない自信はあります私は自分自身をよく見せるために周りの人たちを欺いて
です
ん
[音楽]
自分よく見せるためじゃないけどなんかその人を小ばかにするのはちょっとハスキーが
もしれません私は結果またはリスクほとんど考えることな黄ばみ自分の気分のまま方
ですそんなことはないんですよ割とレッグケアしながら動く方です
そうでもないかも知れそうではないかもしれんなあ私は物事を思い通りに進めたので嘘
をつく嘘というか教えない方が良い場合も多々あると思います
ウソをつくというより教えない方がいいと大事な時もあると私はすぐにカッとなる大抵
そうでもないですね私は大げさな傾向から動画でよく持っちゃうからなんかそういう
気持ちだからな
私は必要に応じて人を傷つけるために理由
をできる技術情報を把握しておくようにしている必要に応じて人を傷つけるために人の
秘密てば面白いですからどっちつかずかな
私は自分の好きなことをやり特に誰に対しても何の義務も感じる事が無いボク動画だし
てる自分が楽しむためだと思ってる
第一で大事なのはねそれ以外いろいろありますけどイーグルエイサーとして何かし
なきゃいけないとか人のために何かさあばいいんじゃないとか重い
ますけど根本的には全く思ってないというと悪い人に映るのでも根本は自分のしたい
ことをするために youtube やってるんで
なんかそれを子ダブルグッドってわけじゃない私は多大に世間から認められ受け入れ
られそして大きな成功を収めるかつなる人間でありますそうありたいよね自信持って
言えるわけではないです私は気に来るものだかなりかなりひねくれものですし
との意見嫌いなんですよ俺やばい奴だな自分で言ってて相当ヤバい奴だと思ってるは
すぐにイライラするそんなこともない失敗車で廃車をいじめたり非難すると楽しむこと
ができるそれは大
1はことも失敗したことありますから非難はしたくない私は他のしている特別だと
感じるつ思いたいですねすべての人々は基本的に敬意おける価値があるまぁ基本はそう
だと思うある程度ですけど私は事故通信できてやるかなり組織に入ってたらわからない
んですけどもユーチューバーとしては自己中でいた方がいいと思ってる私は周りの人
から特別な声低いた体を期待するニャー
そうでもないかの危機だでられると逆に何か期待値が高くなるんでちょっと高いですね
私はしばしば冷淡あるいは無神経だと言われ入っ
周りの人は私に特別に注目すべきだいや
してください終了さあどうなるうわっ
あなたの結果ヘッド a
ナルシシズムマキャベリ兄ズムサイか欲しい人工壁すべてにおいてかなり僕が
プレイですね
[音楽]
あなたの結果平均的な人よりも31.83%
二に近いという疾患でましたハッってたんですけどね普通の人は youtube やっ
て生まれていくとも思わんしね
何かじゃねえパーおかしな人とかやっぱ上がるんじゃないですかそれが魅力かもしれ
ませんしねすね前向きにいを自分のことへじ説明ですね7シリーズも事故
つですねまさに自己2ですまあ間違いない弾み社長ちゃんねるやってるぞず文を出さ
なきゃいけませんから
俺は二こっちで合ってるかなと思うマキャベリ味ズって何
今1打で得た以前関係道徳なのシェアで自己利益と私利私欲のみでの強い感謝と直腸が
ある計算高い策略家であるために目的を達成するまで非常に立体ツールなれ確かに忍耐
強さはリオ何かを達成するためにで最高橋汚したいかもしどんなもんだ
撮影だと違いな紫火星は衝動的な感情反応の予兆があることの特徴でサイコパスの未
発達な肝臓特製お互いストレス耐性他人への低い共感では罪悪感の-3
局留め刺激的な活動セックス暴力麻薬あるいは金銭的リスクやの松がありその結果対人
関係において衝動的なショート向け子が多い人より多い
ただぶっ壊れではねぶっ壊れてな復興
れてますけどないかそーねえ
ギリギリセーフでどこすかねこの新なやばいなてが俺結果やバクレッツに平均いうに
全部高いんだけどかなり凹むわまぁけどなんかこうしていろいろありましたけど社長
やったり映像という分野で活躍しているのか何かしらやっぱ
変なんでしょうねはいとけどダークトライアドテスト自分でどうなんだろうと思った方
ほんと真摯に自分の気持ちに正直になってコンテンツを受けてみたらあなたの社会不
適合者率がわかるかもしれません僕はバッチリ
[音楽]
voodoo
ん
[音楽]